i'm joined by defence analyst at the
royal united services institute dr alex
walmsley good to see you so tell us
about russian troops being pushed back
in the east
the ukrainians have been making
significant advances in the last few
days particularly around kharkiv which
has changed hands now several times in
the course of the 80-day war
they're also making progress further
south in israel and around donetsk
the ukrainians are able to seize russian
equipment abandon tanks artillery and
they're able to do that because they've
got surveillance equipment supplied by
the western allies
and what about in the south of the
country development's there as well in
the south we've been seeing of course
the mario pole siege which is holding
fast but the russians are trying to move
further north west towards zaparisia and
that's very significant because a number
of the people evacuated from mario paul
were taken to zapporigia so they will
then have to be on the move again
further west to safety and in the south
all the way in the south
around mikolaiv
the ukrainians and the russians are
fighting their this significant corridor
the russians are trying to push west
towards odessa the ukrainians are
heading south because they want to keep
access to the sea and that's where
you're seeing
exchange of fires
okay dr alex walmsley thank you